gather your family and friends for
holiday cocktails at Ellis Island
Christina Ellis is back with a special
Ellis Family Recipe you don't want to
miss out on this season how are you I'm
great how are you great it's always
great having you on the show thanks
always great talking with you Amy
brought something very special I did
this is the the Family secret the
holiday eggnog this is a family secret
this is our 20th year okay bottling and
selling the holiday nag at Ellis Island
but it's a family tradition going way
longer than that and can you tell me
what's in it this is like a secret
recipe you can't share anything totally
secret I can't share it I can't share it
it's I've heard about your eggnog it is
legendary here in Las Vegas and but this
is you guys are doing the modeling and
everything we do yeah so we started
bottling it at our Brewery at Ellis
Island 20 years ago I mean cracking the
eggs mixing it the whole thing bottling
it all right on site and it's our 20th
year of uh giving it out so how many
eggs do you think do you guys go through
okay so over the past 20 years if you've
gone through I mean almost 150 000 eggs
really yeah wow okay no there's there's
eggnog and then there's eggnog is this
the one with the kick this is one with
the kick I mean this is a strong eggnog
it it will change all of your
preconceived notions about what eggnog
yeah because I do feel like eggnog gets
a it gets a bad rap for some reason I'm
a fan but I like it I know my eggnog no
absolutely it does get a bad wrap but
once you put some booze in it I mean
better and we're looking at some of the
ways that you guys make it too you put a
little special Twist on it when you
serve it there at the casino you can put
it in coffee it's delicious you can
drink it straight it's amazing Christmas
morning you wake up put some in your
coffee it's a great day okay let's let's
do a pour okay amazing Shake It Up first
that's the thing yeah cinnamon I'll tell
you there is cinnamon in it okay that's
the only thing I'll tell you about okay
well cinnamon and eggs we know that and
eggs we know that yeah it looks good but
I like that I didn't really thought
about that so you wake up you know it's
the holiday season pour that in your
coffee in the mornings you get your
cream kick and you also get a little
extra kick because you might still have
family in town and everything you need
that maybe the kids are crying the tree
is there you know it's the whole thing
is yeah do you have a toast a family
apparently well now I wish we did this
is Grandpa's recipe I figured there'd be
some big speech when we go to drink this
you're right I know first off
that smells good it smells like
Christmas it does let's taste this
oh that's smooth oh you can feel the
nice first of all it's very it's every
it's like um
Christmas in a glass yes the holiday
season glass but then you get that nice
little smoothness of the booze in there
who's New Year's Eve you got some stuff
coming up yes absolutely so every we do
a big fireworks viewing from our parking
garage floor at Ellis Island you have
the best view of the strip you really do
the best view and then inside inside the
front yard we're doing a open bar
fireworks package on our Terrace level
so we'll have some small bites up there
starts at 9 00 p.m you can kind of hang
out wait for the fireworks to go off oh
I love it I love it down there let's go
back to the eggnogs that's why you're
here so this I noticed so you buy this
right now you save it for the holidays
but it's good for a few months right
it's great it'll stay it's refrigerator
safe so keep it in your fridge and you
can leave it there for you know four to
six months and if someone's watching
right now maybe has like a lab or
something you can get this I mean you
break down I want to know what the
Family secret is I want to know I want
to know what's inside there this and so
where do we get where can we buy the
holiday knock at Alexander any of our
restaurants there and at all of our
village pub locations around town are we
shipping it yet across the country not
yet but I mean big things are coming
yeah absolutely well Christina thank you
so much for joining us and cheers to a
happy 2023. yes all right Rocky over to
you